Michael Eric Dyson on the cover of your
book holler if you hear me you have a
little saying that says searching for
Tupac Shakur why are you searching for
him well because he's disappeared from
the common light of our public life and
he's also a murdered figure who still
has a shroud of mystery around him and I
wanted to find out if I could determine
who this real person was the mythology
about him being a thug about him being a
poet about him being a black
revolutionary his pedigree had inherited
from his mother I wanted to figure out
what's the real Tupac Shakur about who
was he what drove him what passions
ignited him and ultimately what was the
meaning of his life when was he killed
September 13 1996 how he was murdered in
a drive-by he was driving well Suge
Knight his record company label head was
driving 750 black BMW and Shakur was
riding unfortunately shotgun and someone
drove up in an automobile and according
to either story stuck a hand out and
fired several fire rounds into the
corridor or got out and then actually
shot at the car door with mr. Shakur
there trying to get into the backseat
mr. Knight pulling him down and two
bullets went through him and he lingered
for six days but technically from the
6th through the 13th 7 days he died on
Friday September 13th how old was he he
was 25 years old why did people think
he's still alive well I think that first
of all the the kind of numerology that
he delved into on his last partially
public published album which is
Machiavelli so he adopted the
Machiavelli character all they changed
the spelling ma ka ve Li and so people
thought well since Machiavelli and the
prince talks about faking one's own
death to maintain power that Tupac
Shakur knew that he was going to quote
be alleged to have died and therefore he
faked his own death to escape
the rat-race he was involved in to
escape the thug life viciousness that he
had become involved in then to escape
his record contract with a company that
had got him out of jail but that now he
wanted to leave for greener pastures but
furthermore I think young people believe
that Tupac is alive because he's the
first black person to integrate this
immortal class of figures like JFK and
Elvis who are believed to still be alive
by their fans there was something
charismatic and tragic about Tupac at
the same time and many of his fans
believe that given his own addiction to
drama that this was the ultimate drama
to escape by pretending that one was
dead so that one could move on in
different spheres of one's life but in
the case of Tupac especially for young
black people I think partly what's going
on is the deflection of the reality of
death that is that people who make some
of the decisions and choices he made end
up being murdered
as a result as a consequence of the
lifestyle that they live and I think
Tupac certainly was a representative of
a destructive as well as edifying life
style for young black people it's
entirely possible that people who
regularly watch this program have never
heard of Tupac Shakur absolutely you
know he was a young man who was born in
the ghetto of New York and Harlem to a
mother who was a revolutionary black
panther figure who was accused of along
with 20 20 other black panther figures
of attempting to blow up fire stations
and to bomb railway stations and so on
in New York City so she was taking the
trial along with her co-defendants she
represented herself and represented the
rest of the Panther 21 as they were
called and she showed an enormous ly
intelligent defense of their position
and got them off right after that a
month after that Tupac was born named
after an Incan conquistador whose body
was ripped apart by Spanish conquerors
so here was a very powerful figure
Afeni Shakur who became the darling of
the left liberal wing of American
politics for you know maybe a couple
maybe about a year
that she was left to her own wits she
became a legal assistant as it was then
known and tried to support her family
but had to go on welfare had a daughter
satchel in 1975 with mutulu shakur who
himself was a black revolutionary black
panther
so Tupac was nurtured in an environment
where he believed that black people
should struggle for self-determination
that they should struggle against white
supremacy that that they should oppose
it with everything that was in them
there had their heart they sold their
bodies as he grew up his mother became
addicted to crack cocaine as a result of
her addiction to crack cocaine Tupac
suffered a series of shall we say you
know domestic setback domestic setbacks
he went from home to home he was
homeless by the time he was 13 he had
lived in 20 different places he went on
to become a serious actor joining the
127th Street ensemble in New York where
he performed the part of Travis in a
Raisin in the Sun the play by Lorraine
Hansberry for Jesse Jackson's 1984
campaign so early on he enjoyed the
spotlight and enjoyed his camaraderie
with these famous black figures he went
on to leave New York at about the age of
15 moved to Baltimore with his mother
and became a member of the Baltimore
School of Arts there which a very
renowned school and he was an enormous
Lee gifted actor everybody there says he
was tremendous even in the school that
it was known for its extraordinary
thespian talent he stood out because of
his spookiness because of his intensity
because of his mastery of his craft he
also studied ballet and art began to
write poetry began to rap a bit met the
actress that would eventually become
Jada Pinkett Smith who became one of his
close friends moved from there at age 17
to Marin City in California and there
attended what they call Mount Tam high
school one of the elite schools in a
very very nicely sequestered School
District there and was known also for
his acting but became disillusioned with
school because it no longer fit his view
of the world in his view of the world
was I'm a young black person trying to
struggle for an authentic identity and
to articulate my viewpoints about the
world and it's not being supported in
school so
he became a rapper after that the name
Shakur where's that come from it's an
Arabic term tupac amaru shining Prince
and Shakur was the common Muslim name
adopted by many of the members of the
Black Panther Party mutulu shakur Assata
Shakur who was formerly known as Joanne
Chesimard who was accused of murdering a
policeman in New Jersey a state
patrolman and is now living in Cuba and
as in fact one of the theories about
Tupac's disappearance is that he's in
Cuba with his adopted godmother Assata
Shakur chilling out from the vicious
chaos of his life his mother you say her
name is a Fenny Afeni Shakur Rae where
does she live she lives now in a Stone
Mountain Georgia with in a house that
Tupac bought her with the proceeds from
the down payment on his first three
albums for death row records death row
head label head Suge Knight which is now
called the records not death row records
since he has been released from jail he
was in prison for four years he went to
prison where Tupac was in Rikers Island
and Clinton Correctional Facility and
had him sign a three-page handwritten
contract that was the basis of their
relationship professional relationship
and the last company for for which Tupac
worked so he signed that contract he
said I need a house of my mother and so
a house was purchased for two bucks
mother and that's the house in Stone
Mountain Georgia how much did she
cooperate with you for this book very
much so she was very cooperative
I think Geronimo Pratt another black
panther who served 27 years in prison
until he was released a client of then
young unknown attorney Johnnie Cochran
so Geronimo Pratt forged a connection
between me and Miss Shakur and she was
quite cooperative and very moving and
touching and quite honest about her own
faults her own frailties and her own
troubles how old is she now she's in her
early 50s and why does she want a book
written about her son well because she
understands that Tupac was a in the
words of Hegel a world historical figure
he was a very important young man even
though
mainstream society may not have been
attuned to his importance she understood
that this was a figure who's not only
important for african-american youth or
for pop culture but he's a figure in
whom we can see the contesting will of
somebody who wants to be smart and
intelligent on the one hand and on the
other hand somebody who got caught up in
some self-destructive habits she sees
her son as an exemplar of the best and
the brightest of african-american
culture and she sees him as a symbol of
a generation that continues to fight for
legitimacy and a culture that often
doesn't recognize it we're gonna run a
little excerpt from one of his albums
it's actually an excerpt from the I
don't know if you call his songs yeah I
guess here they are songs right and this
is the one about his mother dear mama
what's the what's the origin of this
well Tupac had written his mother a
nine-page letter when she indicated that
she was in recovery for her crack
addiction and he said to her I
appreciate what you've done but you
can't expect me overnight to accept your
word that you will stay clean simply
because you said so and so he struggled
mightily this is right when he was
becoming famous struggled mightily with
her decision to go into rehabilitation
and whether or not it was a legitimate
one he certainly understood later on
that it was so this was his way of
making up with her in public of
forgiving her of offering an olive
branch so to speak to to bring more
tranquility to their domestic
relationship and so this dear mama was
him speaking from his heart a gesture of
love a gesture of also criticism but an
acknowledgement that you are a serious
woman and that there have been serious
odds against you have you ever did you
ever meet him by the way never met him
how popular was he at his height Oh
extraordinarily so I mean like money how
did he make a lot of money he made a ton
of money and spent a ton of money
because he had you know some argue up to
40 friends and relatives that he was
taking care of at the time of his death
but his second album debuted at the top
of the charts his third album me against
the world debuted when he was in prison
for a charge a conviction of sexual
abuse it
in charge of sodomy and rape but he was
according to those charges and accused
of forcibly touching a woman's buttocks
so he his album debuted at the top of
the charts in his next album All Eyez on
Me was just the first double album in
the history of hip hop culture went on
to sell something like 7 million copies
so he was extraordinarily popular made
it into a huge sum of money and spent a
huge sum of money because he was a very
compassionate young man who believed
that he was responsible for taking care
of his family was your when he died was
your money left well there's that was
the argument um Death Row Records
claimed that Tupac owed them money as a
result of his lavish lifestyle living in
the peninsula hotel the cars that we're
just Peninsula Hotel in Los Angeles
California and the cars that he
purchased and just lavishing gifts on
women and so on whereas the estate that
was headed by a Fanny Shakur his mother
claimed that he was old millions of
dollars so they went to court and
finally settled by giving the rights of
that music to Afeni Shakur and amaru
Records but he certainly has generated
millions of dollars since his death and
continues to his estate continues to
collect but why did Suge Knight go to
prison he went to prison because the
night of the Tupac Shakur was murdered
they were attending a Bruce Seldon fight
and Mike Tyson fight in Las Vegas at the
MGM at the MGM as they were exiting the
fight somebody told Tupac Shakur we
think we see a guy who snatched one of
the death row pendants from one of their
fellow artists Tupac then pursued him
his name was Orlando Anderson all of
them that is the entourage of Tupac and
Suge Knight began to get in kicks and
hits into a sail the young man he
pressed no charges he was allegedly a
member of the Crips Suge Knight was
allegedly a member of the Bloods and
Tupac was closely allied with him and he
was brought up on charges of violating
his probation he had a previous charge
involving guns and so on so he was sent
to jail for nine years he served about
four and a half years of that uh
sentence
you you got into this how well I'm a fan
of huge fan of hip-hop I was a teen
father but first what's a hip what does
it mean by hip hop
well hip hop is the term assigned to rap
music not only rap music but the larger
culture out of which rap music issues
some say coupe DJ Kool Herc came up with
the term some say who's a famous person
within rap music
some say it was somebody else but the
term suggests something about the beat
the rhythm the passion of urban street
life and I was a huge fan of that kind
of music because I was a teen father I
knew my son was attracted to that I
wanted to find a way to be able to reach
him to bridge the gulf generationally
speaking but also because I was a member
of a family that was deeply into music I
grew up in Detroit Michigan in the inner
city there and so my father and mother
listened to everything from blues jazz
and R&B so I was deeply attracted to the
music how old were you in had your first
son I was a 19 years old how old is he
today he is 23 years old now one of your
sons and here you quote saying they said
to you that had this I mean I get the
quote you probably remember exactly I'm
talking about right that's that's him
that's Michael Eric guys in a second he
said pops you know dad had you met to
puck I think he might have lived why do
you why does he think that well that's
the generosity of a son thinking that
his father has the answer for young
people who may be in trouble given some
of his own experiences and the way I've
been able to manage some of the chaos in
his own life but also because of our the
mutual love and admiration we share and
him you know he understood that I loved
hip-hop coaching that I had an enormous
love for tupac shakur long before he
died
I was attracted to him as a person who
didn't possess the greatest skills in
terms of what rap music is about poetic
meters intense focus on using metaphor
and simile and all of these other
rhetorical flourishes that are common to
the lyric conventions of hip-hop but he
had a heart that was huge and a vision
that was was Catholic small see in a
vision that was complex and I was
attracted to that vision and he knew
that I was attracted to this young man
so he felt that had I been able as a
Baptist minister as well as a professor
and as
well as a father and as a black man been
able to reach out to him perhaps he
might have been saved where do you make
home today I'm in Chicago I teach at
DePaul University and I live in Chicago
Illinois what do you teach I teach
religious studies I teach classes I'm a
university professor which means pretty
much I can teach in any department I
choose I'm my basis and religion and in
philosophy now teach courses and
critical race Theory courses on popular
culture courses on the radical legacy of
Martin Luther King jr. recently and
where did you get your own education my
undergraduate is from Carson Newman
College a small southern baptists school
30 miles outside of Knoxville Tennessee
in Jefferson City Tennessee I did a BA
there my MA and PhD are from Princeton
University and religion what did you do
after Princeton I left Princeton to
teach at Hartford seminary for a year
and after I left and direct a poverty
program and then left Hartford to go to
Chicago for the first time for three
years from 89 to 92 to teach at
Chicago's Theological Seminary I left
there in 92 to teach at Brown University
for two years and then there on to
University of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill for three years teach I taught at
Columbia University in New York for two
years and now I've been in Chicago this
is going on my third year there's a lot
of black culture in your book yes for
people who never thought I would never
read about it I want to ask you some of
those things that you write about what's
a homie a homie is one's friend one's
associate and it's the kind of ebon
asides or ghetto discourse the hip-hop
ghetto discourse that suggests this is
my homeboy it's a shorting of homeboy
and homeboy is the signal signifying a
friend a friend close to the heart
somebody that I grew up with somebody
that's in my neighborhood that I kick it
with kick it with associated with and so
homie is the shortened version of that
what's a hoe a hole is in many ways in
hip-hop discourse a derisive term
referring to a female of loose sexuality
that's it's specific and technical term
more loosely it's used for young black
women or Latina women perhaps within the
hip-hop and ghetto culture who are
viewed to be easily accessible so
once a [ __ ] a [ __ ] is a woman who is
viewed as that's interesting a woman who
is viewed as not only a hole but a
person who will be quite nasty and
temperamental in the aftermath of
whatever sexual transaction might take
place on the other hand given the kind
of patriarchal culture that is that is
just endemic to so much hip-hop a [ __ ]
maybe a woman who refuses to engage in
sexual exchange in liaison with about a
young man or one who since has a sense
of her own dignity and possesses a sense
of her own identity who doesn't give in
easily to the whim and caprice of a man
so [ __ ] is a pejorative term a nasty
term a derisive term used for a wide
variety of women unfortunately even in
this quote positive songs think of
notorious b.i.g s me and my [ __ ] he
didn't mean that derisively he meant it
as a term of endearment some women in
hip-hop called themselves [ __ ] each
other [ __ ] and many of the men who
call women [ __ ] don't mean anything
negative by that's the kind of
terminological twists that have gone on
in hip-hop culture that are very
controversial as you know on the
internet all the words for these Tunes
that he sang is there and and I don't
know I can't be sure but most of them we
couldn't read write primarily you
couldn't read it because of one word
it's used all the time the f-word right
or put mother in front of it which is
you I always want to know why is that
such a why is it used so often and in
this culture well I think that there's
something sensual and something earthy
about the the f-word the MF word in
particular technically of course F uck
fornicating under consent of the king so
it's a kind of twist of a King James
terminology into the transience of black
culture what's interesting is that
there's a sensual characteristic it's
it's a it's a catch-all term it can be
something negative it can be something
positive hey you my MF or watch out MF
so it's an all-purpose term that has
allowed a wide range of emotion to be
condensed into its into its use and so I
think that that many African American
so-called ghetto centric youth that is
people who are
attached to the ghetto to the inner-city
and not just there by the way find a
kind of verbal release kind of a
neurotic attachment to this very sensual
and very charged terminology the same
way with the other word that is the
n-word and Tupac used that word quite
frequently in the larger white
supremacist discourse is called [ __ ]
but Tupac and many african-american
youth and not only youth talked about it
as [ __ ] ni GGA now he said in one of
his songs
words of wisdom ni GGA meant for him
never ignorant getting goals
accomplished some black people don't buy
that they see altogether negative
connotations associated with the word no
matter how many black people try to
transform it into something different
that's why my book I talk about those
who are reservationist who have
reservations about the term and those
who are revisionist those who say no we
can do something with it like gay and
lesbian people take the word queer which
is meant as a pejorative and something
negative and say you darn right I'm
queer and use it as a term that is
positive black people have attempted
throughout their own history to take and
seize the term [ __ ] and turn it around
to make it something positive there's a
picture here this isn't the best I can't
find the best one but on his body were
several tattoos and this looks like it
was an earlier version when he was
younger right but if you look real close
here you can see 50 [ __ ] right right
right what does that mean
well that was his term that was his
belief that was his inscription on his
body to suggest that he was down with
his homies in all 50 states all black
people who were part of the ghetto
economy the illicit the underground
economy selling drugs being a thug or
just black people caught in the environs
of the inner city he was representing
them 50 [ __ ] behind me in all 50
states that is black people in every
state of the United States of America
are joined in to my body and joined with
me in the struggle against the odds
here's another photograph actually this
is a better one but first of all I want
to ask you about right there on his
stomach is Thug thug life thug life
right
what's a thug and what's thug life well
for Tupac a thug was a person who had
nothing it was it was more useful than
the term gangsta gangsta was
determinated with so-called hardcore
Rep by the mainstream media but Tupac
believed that thug was much more
resonant because it was suggestive of an
illicit economy underground economy and
a black person who had nothing and who
was willing to hustle for anything that
he could get thug life for him meant
something very specific
it meant the hate it was another acronym
the hate you gave little infants F's
everyone and so his point was that a
thug was a person who had nothing to
lose a thug was a person who as a result
of mistreatment by the American
government was had risen to become its
worst nightmare and becoming its worst
nightmare was intelligent about the ways
in which it resisted the forces of
oppression so he believed that something
positive was going on when he talked
about being a thug if you notice here
this is the way he dressed he has his
underwear on there with the jeans that
he's got on right on his hips below and
then the the baggy trousers and as you
know that's everywhere everybody right
great white and black kids dressed this
way it's universal so low slung sagging
jeans that is imitative of the prison
culture one of the reason culture right
absolutely shoelaces not in the shoes
that was a result of course in prison
they didn't want people to hang
themselves no belts on the trousers so
in one sense partly it is inspired by
prison culture and the way in which
prison culture of course is so tied up
with black masculine culture for the
last 25 years given the extraordinarily
disproportion numbers of black men who
are in prison so that filtered back
through prison culture and the irony of
course is that black men who were who
and Latino men who helped perpetuate
that culture can't enjoy the enormous
sums of money that are reaped as a
result of uh you know the the designers
who make you know money off that Tommy
Hilfiger and others who make enormous
money off of that so it's very
controversial in these cantana me he'll
figure a white a white designer who has
made enormous sums of money off of the
styles and dress of African America does
that ever bother African American
absolutely well they're they're even
conspiracy theories out there and rumors
about Tommy Hilfiger one quote said that
Tommy Hill
went on Oprah and suggested that he
didn't like the very black people that
were attracted to his dress of course
that was easily discounted because he
never appeared on Oprah to say those
words but the that was a way I think of
the everyday black person to discount
the way in which Tommy Hilfiger has made
enormous sums of money off of black
culture and reaped enormous benefit
without being perceived to be part of
that culture or at least giving back to
it or least even attracted to it so
there was some kind of gossip that was a
form of social critique directed to him
I noticed that a lot of his friends
shortened it from two pocketers Tupac
right exactly that was a way of showing
love and affection and as a nickname
there's a picture here also when I asked
you about because around his neck is a
cross right what is that for well you
know the Jesus piece as the hip hoppers
call it the rappers call it the cross
that is usually diamond-encrusted or
with platinum my son even has one
certainly not a nearly as expensive as
that one but it's suggestive of the
religious traditions of black culture is
suggestive of a style and a trend within
hip-hop where one gives kudos to God
even as one talks about killing one's
neighbor but it's also suggestive of
Tupac's deep and profound spirituality
and there it is again
him always professing a belief in God a
nontraditional an unorthodox want to be
sure but nonetheless a deeply spiritual
person who was preoccupied with God on
many of his albums there's a song called
only god can judge me now where he says
somebody help me tell me where to go
from here cuz even thugs cry but do the
lord care so he was deeply and
profoundly obsessed with God in much of
his music was he political deeply
political in fact he began as a very
political animal Tupac began as a kind
of you know rapper who was more
associated with the quote positive and
political rap I would say a person like
Chuck D Chuck D is the head rapper of
the group Public Enemy which rose to
prominence in the late 80s and early 90s
in America and explained another group
from the east that was deeply and
profoundly cultural and political
African centered conscious of their
cultural roots and deeply determined to
bring you know change to American
society so Tupac initially was just part
of that because he was a child of
a black panther he talked about being a
child of a black panther he has a song
on holler if you hear me from which my
book title was taken where he says just
the other day I got lynched by some
crooked cops into the state those same
cops on the beat getting major pay but
when I get my check they take in tax out
so we paying the pigs to knock the
blacks out so he was deeply political
even as he evolved and grew to embrace
the culture he was always political in
the midst of that you say that Snoop
Doggy Dogg or Snoop Dogg as a calling
rate would not be interviewed by you
yeah I attempted to interview him not in
the most suspicious occasions but I
attempted to get at him at a free
concert he was giving for one of the
shoe companies for whom he endorsed
shoes tell that story around how you
tried to get to him
well I'd you know tried all of the other
channels of writing and talking and
calling folk and so on and getting other
stars to call them and using whatever
little leverage I have as as an
intellectual of who's notorious perhaps
in je but nothing works so what I did is
um I attended this concert and somebody
who had seen me in a hotel knew me and
saw me and said look I'll get you into
the to the green room so to speak and
you can go from there so I went there
who is he by the way uh four people at
this young new dogs new dog is one of
the most famous west coast rappers who
has a kind of southern cadence to his
talk and a flow one two three into the
faux Snoop Doggy Dogg and dr. Drake is
at the dough ready to make an entrance
so bad going up because you know we bout
to rip stuff up so he is that slow
cadence that is an index of the great
black migration that I'm sure his
parents participated in they call it a
Caliban accent California Alabama in the
southern regions joined together so
Snoop Dogg is a very famous rapper who
was part of death row who also recorded
with Tupac Shakur a couple of three
songs and I wanted to talk to him
because I knew he was a friend of
Tupac's I knew he had appeared in his
videos I know they were mutually
supportive of one another and admiring
of one another but he also is in
tremendous disagreement and in a very
tense relationship with should night who
is his former label hit - Snoop Dogg
left Death Row Records when
a Suge Knight went to jail and then join
with Master P's priority records in New
Orleans and so now he has his own record
label so there was tremendous tension
and they were at odds so anybody coming
up to him to speak about Tupac Shakur
the desert or the death road days
I think sent a red flag up to him and he
was quite cautious about that and I
wasn't able to to get him I you know he
was walking along I had a couple of
words with him but nothing from him
so I ended up interviewing people around
him and it was uh just as useful if not
more useful to me for my book end for
the purposes of getting a keener insight
into who Tupac really was so I met with
Larenz Tate their tremendous brilliant
young actor whose acted in several films
including dead presidents of the Hughes
brothers a monumental film about black
participation in Vietnam and then the
dreadful consequences of returning home
I talked to him and he gave me some
insight about two pockets quote the
black Elvis
I spoke to Ray J the younger brother of
brandy Norwood the singer and actor on
the recently counseled Moishe show and
he stars on it himself and he talked
about Tupac's thug life being attracted
to him because a thug for him meant
being young and black and getting money
but I also spoke to two big tradie and
that was probably the most moving
interview I did in that that day and
perhaps with the exception of a finish
occurred throughout the entire sixty
interviews I did and I approached him he
was a jheri curl Din the that's the
style of hair that was lightly permed in
the late 80s that was common in black
culture that men and women in war and so
he was a throwback so to speak to the
late 80s with his cap on there with his
little daughter freckled face you know
gang thug life but he was a very gentle
man and I sat down to speak with him and
after speaking with him and he told me
about Tupac's genius and his work ethic
and his spirituality and the tragedy of
his not being able to enjoy the rest of
his life like Michael Jackson or Donald
Trump to see the millions of dollars and
the kudos that would come his way and
the accolades that would accumulate he
after he finished he began to cry
silently sobbing into the napkins that I
provided for him for a good 20 minutes
just tears streaming down his eyes
reddening his eyes his daughter
I was in quite a bit of consternation
thinking that I had somehow done
something negative or awful to her
father but it was very moving to me to
see this so-called hard figure just
wordlessly pouring his anguish into this
cloth bespeaking
so much about the passion and love that
tupac generated and so many people
where's this all going well in terms of
the book or in turn now just the culture
and and and I know you have for instance
Stan crouches in your book taking
another point of view have strong
criticisms right right I mean how many
in the black world how many people like
all this and how many people don't like
it do you have any sense it's deeply
divided I mean there's a deep division
in black America precisely over hip-hop
culture and the the tremendous tensions
that go between the civil rights
generation so-called and the hip-hop
culture that's why my book on Martin
King jr. I talked about King and the hip
hop generation a lot of people get a lot
of black people thought you know that's
really sacrilegious how ridiculous is
that and it doesn't have the real
intellectual payoff that you might think
and my point was not to bring dr. King
down this is so called a Tupac Shakur's
level they're not moral equivalence I
wasn't that silly what I was trying to
suggest is that some of the same faults
and foibles that we forgive King for we
nail these young kids for and they're in
the process of growing up in public and
I wanted to suggest that there's a deep
division in black America about the
virtue or the value of hip-hop culture I
happen to think that it's a much more
complex phenomenon that needs to be
supported and that needs to be
criticized to be sure but also needs to
be examined for its complexity and if we
have one broad stroke with which we
paint the entire culture against the
canopy of our disdain then we're really
dismissing what is essentially the most
powerful form of popular culture for the
last 25 years and certainly the most
invigorating black popular culture the
last you know at least couple decades
was Tupac Shakur a misogynist he was at
one level he was out well because he
used terrible names to talk about women
he had tremendous resentment and disdain
for and I coined this term FEMA for
which is like homophobia it's not quite
misogyny which is the cruel hatred of
women or sexism or the centum
it's expressed against women or
patriarchy which is the systematic
belief that men's perspectives ought to
be the norm for the entire society what
I meant by film phobia was there's a
kind of resentment and the kind of fear
of women that you see nurtured in many
of these enclaves of civic Terror called
ghettoes and slums and Tupac
participated in that but he was a
misogynist as well because I think you
know by using terms like [ __ ] and hope
for women but also by suggesting that
they should be at his beck and call
sexually uh you know bolide a certain
kind of negative viewpoint of women but
he also was embracing them you listen to
dear mama and the beauty and the
touching nature of his uh you know
celebration of his mother or keep you
hit up I give a shout to my sisters on
welfare if no one cares Tupac cares so
he was both a misogynist and a person
who could deeply and profoundly embrace
women you wrote everybody kept throwing
his body his beautiful tattooed wounded
conflicted drugged lurching
representative fighting cursing defiant
loving needy sacrificial body in the way
yes well Tupac as all artists was
profoundly you know expressive through
his body but even more so the tattoos on
his body represented his projection to
the world of black masculine identity
what it meant to live to the lethal
limits of thug life what it meant to be
a nobody what it meant to be a [ __ ]
what it meant to be somebody who had
Spurgeon's caste against him so he
wanted to represent symbolically black
identity black youth identity and more
specifically black male identity but his
body was very crucial to his message his
beautiful eyes his eyelashes you know he
was seen as a pretty young black man was
coming up and and that caused him quite
a bit of consternation because you know
the association the the homoerotic
association so he wanted to distance
himself himself from that but women were
attracted to him profoundly because of
his sexuality and because of his
sensuality because of his beautiful skin
is beautiful smiled his amazingly
charismatic presence and that body of
course was the source of both pleasure
and pain to him I think he lived rather
uneasily in his body he didn't he rarely
if ever
about being good-looking as some
wherever's I want to do he didn't talk
about his sexual prowess in relationship
to his good looks it was only as a
result of his connection to third life
because thugs are to have many women to
love none of them and to get around so
to speak that is to be promiscuous and
in that sense he talked about when
female sexuality but he never spoke
about it in terms of his own belief in
his own beauty because I think he was
quite uncomfortable with that is
Danielle Smith a former editor of a
magazine made quite clear just want to
ask you a question about the rag on the
head right the bend n another where does
that come from that's associated with
gang culture in LA and before Tupac the
bandana was seen as a as a very negative
and provocative headgear
but after him it became quite popular
and people beyond gang culture began to
adopt it as a source of a style what do
you hope your book does I hope it
educates people about the complexity of
this young man I hope it opens their
eyes and their minds to receive some of
his messages while still being critical
of him as I am in the book I have an
entire chapter about his extraordinarily
extraordinarily powerful intelligence
the way he read voraciously he was he
consumed books in a fashion that is
associated with professors and not
necessarily with ghetto residents and I
wanted to reject and repudiate the
vicious stereotypes that prevail about
not only Tupac but about this culture in
general I'm not suggesting that all of
them or even most of them read as much
as he does but I think that they're
highly intelligent if you listen to some
of the narratives of a person like most
deaf who's quoted on the back of my book
when he said you can laugh and criticize
Michael Jackson if you want to Woody
Allen molested in mérida stepdaughters
saying press kick and dirt on Michael's
name
sure woody and soon-yi at the playoff
game so there's high intelligence in
there there's narrative complexity
there's poor take intensity and in Tupac
here was a figure who read widely
feminist theory he read George Orwell he
read James Baldwin and Nikki Giovanni he
read broadly in self healing arts in
method acting I just wanted to suggest
that this was a complex beautiful
self-destructive confused edifying young
man who brought both the glory and the
grief of black culture to live in
one body what's the story of Lila
Steinberg Lela Steinberg Lela
yes Lela Steinberg Lela Steinberg is a
multi-ethnic white woman who lives who
lives in in Oakland California when are
we talking about we're talking about in
the late 80s we're talking about and she
lived there before Tupac
but Tupac moved there in the late 80s
and he met her in a park when she was a
teacher who gave workshops in the local
schools because she had children in
those schools she wanted to make sure
that they were being sufficiently
addressed in regard to their educational
needs and so she volunteered initially
and then began to give began to give
workshops on writing and poetry and
rhythms and so on and she met Tupac one
day in a park in Marin City where white
white woman yes and she had danced with
him the previous night unbeknownst to
her or Tupac how is that well because
her husband was her then-husband was a
DJ and they gave party so not only did
she teach in school during the day but
at night she and her husband gave
parties that drew up to ten thousand
kids and he was a black man and he was a
black man so they were interracially
married and she was deeply attracted to
the hip-hop culture because of its
honesty it's a visceral attachment to
black your urban and street culture and
because as an artist she knew that this
art spoke the truth to power and to the
powerless and so that night a beautiful
young man came to dance with on the
dance floor because she was so absorbed
in her own responsibilities that I
didn't get a chance to get his name but
the next day when she was reading her
book in the park when he Mandela's book
part of my soul went with him he came up
and said what do you know about Winnie
Mandela how old is she she's uh
now she's 40 years old and so Tupac was
then 17 and she was in the near 30 and
she said well I you know I'm just
starting to read the book and he began
to quote to her passages from the book
verbatim so she was deeply struck so
they struck up a conversation one thing
led to another he went to her workshop
that after
and then in short order moved in with
her she had been looking for a rapper to
bring some kind of social
conscientiousness join to political
responsibility to the classroom as well
as her workshops and she found her
figure in Tupac and she became his first
manager and even though she turned him
over to a truant Gregory who was then
managing a group called Digital
Underground which is based in Oakland
California she turned him over to Tupac
over to him she stayed in contact with
him continued to give him advice
continued to chide him continue to argue
with him about his choices and decisions
what was her reaction when he was killed
she was deeply wounded but she knew it
was coming she felt that death was
knocking on his door he had given to her
a poem called in the event of my demise
written when he was 21 yet were 21 years
old and so she knew that in some fashion
some way the two parks death even though
she tried to deny it was almost
inevitable it made inevitable by the
choices he made rendered inevitable by
the lifestyle he was living in the
people with whom he associated who do
people think killed him whether all kind
of theories do you have a one yeah you
know what after poring over all this
stuff I think that what happened that
night in the MGM at the bloody mic type
right mice Tyson Mike Tyson fight in
Vegas is that when Tupac led the volley
of fists against this young man Orlando
Anderson who was a [ __ ] part of a gang
out there the rival gang - the Bloods
out there in LA I think that he sought
revenge that night or at least somebody
in the Crips sought revenge that night
and you know as a result of that gang
warfare rolled up on Tupac so to speak
by drive-by and exact revenge but that's
just a theory I have no proof of that at
all but given the kind of gang
retribution that goes on very commonly
in Los Angeles between the Bloods and
the Crips it would not be a far-fetched
theory to suggest that it was in
response to his beating of this young
man how are you critical of him well I'm
critical of the self-destructive choices
that he made in regard
- talking about women the way he does
and I devote an entire chapter to his
complexities on women I'm critical of
him in terms of trying to be a quote
real [ __ ] and reducing a authentic
black person to a person who lives in
the ghetto have been come from the
ghetto myself I understand that
inclination and appreciate his giving
visibility to those who are often denied
access to the mainstream culture as
legitimately positive people but at the
same time to reduce the complexity of
black culture to the ghetto and to
suggest that if you're not acting as if
you are in the ghetto and more
importantly that the ghetto is all about
being a thug or a pimp or a player so to
speak a person who's promiscuous with
women as opposed to somebody who attends
Sunday school or takes lessons with the
local musician to reduce the complexity
of the ghetto to even a thug I think is
misdirected and to see black
authenticity linked primarily or
exclusively to the ghetto is as mislead
as the bushwa sensibilities that try to
distance black people from the ghetto
altogether was there anything about his
lifestyle that you like and you'd like
to live yourself well certainly having
the luxury and leisure to be able to
support one's family to have their
economic wherewithal to give sustenance
to the people that you love that is
remarkable and people who have far more
money than he did don't do that
so his compassion his altruism was
extraordinary not simply to his family
but to his friends and those people that
he happened to meet and so I envy him
that possibility is there in all of rap
music is there ever a message in the
music that encourages a young black
person to get out of the world of the
ghetto and into another lifestyle sure
even to puck himself in a song called I
ain't mad at you talked about the
extraordinary tensions that result when
a person who had formerly been part of a
ghetto click you know converts to
becoming a Muslim and as a result of
that doesn't want to associate anymore
with that lifestyle and Tupac says you
know that's fine because getting I'm not
mad at you he says I'm not angry at you
for wanting to get out of the ghetto
there are many up from the ghetto
stories in hip-hop culture similar to
Booker T Washington's up from slavery
reproduced more than 100 years later and
the upward mobility and the striving of
young black people this is why I think
there's an opposite extreme of
celebrating too much of materialism
you know the bling-bling the bling-bling
is this sight that is produced when a
platinum or diamond encrusted watch
reflects the light bling-bling and so
there's a bling-bling school of rap that
celebrates materialism and the
acquisition of cars and so on that is
just as I think egregiously outrageously
false as anything that goes on in their
minds as being a fake Negro that is a
person who speaks a certain way and
whose diction reflects a certain level
of education that is anathema to the so
called ghetto resident and I think this
bling-bling culture is ridiculous
exaggeration of the materialism that has
really gutted so much a hip hop at least
one variety of hip-hop can you explain
the story of Sean puffy combs he was
accused and prosecuted something he was
acquitted for done Atlanta I believe my
day like right in in New York yes
explain though how you go from a Sean
puffy combs peed pump dad right right
right and then change your name and it
and it's totally accepted to P Diddy
what does all that mean right well you
know Sean puffy combs of course in an
extraordinary entrepreneur whose empires
now over 300 million dollars traded on
his Street credibility because he
started record label Bad Boy Records
that was the major competitor for death
row on the west coast so this East Coast
versus West Coast was set up in part by
the rivalry between bad boy which was
puffy combs his label and death row
which was Suge Knight's label and their
major stars puffy combs as major Starr
was the notorious b.i.g better known as
biggie smalls nay Christopher Wallace
and what happened to him he was murdered
and drive-by six months after Tupac was
killed in Los Angeles after attending
the Soul Train Music Awards was he east
or west
he was East Coast so some people see
that as retribution for and revenge for
the murder of Tupac Shakur he died in
March of nineteen
97 so he was the major star for Bad Boy
Records Tupac was the major star for
death row records and this East Coast
West Coast rivalry was fomented by two
pucks
I think lethal addiction to stirring up
trouble and he believed honestly at some
level although I don't think he always
believed it that Biggie Smalls was
responsible for the first attempt of his
life which happened in 19 I think 93 no
no I think it was in 95 as a matter of
fact when he was shot five times when he
was trying to get into a recording
studio in Times Square quad studio and
was obviously the victim of an attempted
robbery and he believed that later on
that puffy and notorious b.i.g set him
up
so Puff Daddy traded on his Street
credibility he was both the streetwise
kid who could ring up enormous sales of
the hardest core rap one might imagine
on the East Coast while also trading in
his Hamptons cachet by being a you know
friends with Martha Stewart or throwing
Tony parties out in the Hamptons so he
was both an and he was able to cross
that cultural divide but he played on
that thug image he played on that
bad-boy image quite vigorously but that
bad-boy image redounded on him in a
negative way during his recent trial
when he and a young man named Cheyne
Barrow who ended up being a convicted of
10 years in jail were accused of
shooting a gun at some people in and
hitting of what three people in a
nightclub in New York City Sean puffy
combs was acquitted shine barrel was a
convicted and is now serving ten years
in prison
after that puffy had a kind of religious
revelation and the conversion experience
where he said I'm going to change my
name you know that's an old tradition
not only in black culture but in
religious culture but in special
especially I told Jesus it would be all
right if he changed my name so puffy had
a very public conversion from puffy to P
Diddy and P Diddy is just a term that
that is a term of affection that
actually Biggie Smalls gave to him
before he died so
he signified his conversion from the old
bad-boy image to the new image of a
quote cleaned up reformed rapper who is
quite more cautious about the thug image
that he promoted before so Atlanta I
said Atlanta is New York right here see
what's the weed Creed
well the weed Creed is the almost
uncritical celebration of smoking ganja
of smoking marijuana in in black ghetto
culture among young people and Latino
culture as well and the weed creed is
about celebrating weeds possibilities of
not only expanding one's artistic vision
but also as a symptom of one's ghetto
authenticity and Tupac consumed copious
amounts of Alizee and Hennessy his
drinks of choice as well as enormous
amounts of weed Jada pinkett-smith right
did he want to marry her he certainly
did in prison when he was serving an
eight month term for his sexual abuse
Tupac was going through a conversion of
sorts himself he renounced after all
thug life he talked to the journalist
Kevin Powell in vibe magazine and he
gave an interview said listen thug life
is over it was something that was
important it was a stage in my own life
but I'm through with thug life and he
also said that he wanted to become much
more serious about his commitment to
furthering his life and his goals and
his ambitions writing screenplays and
saw etcetera but also he felt that this
was the appropriate time to settle down
so he extended an invitation to marriage
to Jada Pinkett and of course she
summarily refused that although she told
me that she considered it for a while
she said with my given her own history
she said of codependency she she thought
she entertained it for a while but knew
that it was not the right decision and I
asked her directly that she and Tupac
ever have a relationship excuse me other
than friendship and she said no but
Tupac felt that she was
a person who knew him because she was
after all a member of the Baltimore
School of Arts there and was a fellow
actor and she defended him to gangs
there and loved him as a brother and as
a result of that he was deeply attracted
and attached to her but she turned about
he ended up marrying a woman named
Keisha Morris but that marriage was
annulled once he left prison give me
children no he had no children even
though he had many songs and a letter to
my unborn child letter to my firstborn
he never got a chance to to have a child
some more terms the player sent me the
player is that figure in black ghetto
discourse who is the person who is a
promiscuous person he has several women
in his stable is not completely or
exclusively or to any of them but keeps
them at his beck and call the Mac the
Mac is an a kind of super player but a
person who is able to reproduce the
vision of himself as the supreme
determiner of the fate of women and he
lives off of the largesse of women he
lives off of their good graces so if he
she allows him to pimp them or allows
him to use her car her so for her house
and so on he takes great delight and
pleasure in controlling women the
hustler the hustler is more generically
a figure who in one sense is the person
who is capable of using his or her
mother wit to make a go at life more
specifically but within ghetto discourse
the hustler is the person who would do
whatever is necessary to get over and
provide for himself or herself or button
usually himself in his family have you
gotten any feedback from Afeni the
mother Tupac Shakur about this book yes
she's quite pleased she cooperated with
me in doing this book by giving me an
interview and allowing me you know there
was this is not a sponsored book it's
not an official book it is an
independently done book it's an exercise
and cultural criticism but she was very
cooperative and she's very pleased that
another book on her son is out there to
try to dispel some of the myths
to try to speak to his genius and to try
to embrace him as a figure worthy of
scholarly scrutiny you listen to his
music still absolutely absolutely I'm
riveted by him I'm drawn to him
I view him as a kind of hip-hop Marvin
Gaye his mood his tone of voice is
beautiful eloquence his fiery
declarations and sometimes his arrogance
and bravura are an interesting
alchemical mix and I think that you know
songs like unconditional love songs like
keep your head up songs like dear mama
but also his songs that are that prove
his addiction to death
life goes on only god can judge me now
his religious sensibilities that are
seen on his album Machiavelli in the
song blasphemy I'm just attracted to his
enormous and profound complexity and the
way in which he refuses to be one thing
did here's a picture of him when he was
quite young yeah did he know who his
father was
he only discovered the identity of his
father when he was shot five times and
recovering in a New York Hospital when
he awakened from his sleep and surgery
to discover his spitting image staring
at him thinking that he was in heaven
it literally scared him out of that how
hospital he left that hospital that day
ostensibly to get away from people who
might still be gunning for him and he
took refuge in Jasmine guy's house the
actress Oh is his father's name his
father's name is Billy Garland but he
didn't know initially who his father was
until you know he was in his 20s he had
no idea who his father was it could have
been Lumumba the man who Afeni Shakur
allegedly married but who's also a black
panther organizer it could have been
legs who was a member of Nicky Barnes
and stable Nicky Barnes was a notorious
Harlem gangster or could have been Billy
Garland a black panther himself he
didn't discover until he was in his 20s
right before here's before he died that
it indeed his father his blood father
was Billy Garland this is the cover of
the book author Michael Eric Dyson the
book holler if you hear me looking for
Tupac
Shakur thank you very much thank you
very calm